four-time Mr Olympia social media star
and multi-million dollar businessman Jay
Cutler is larger than life in business
he's pulling in millions of dollars a
year his dedication is unparalleled and
growing up he was a major inspiration
for me to get into fitness this is going
to be an incredible episode make sure to
subscribe because we have episodes
coming out like this every single week
here on the ice coffee hour
[Music]
this all happened because of a very
funny situation where Graham came up to
me he's like dude you'll never guess
what happened man I was out at the
casino and I met Jay Cutler and I was
like yeah do you remember this I don't
remember this was that Resorts World it
was the opening okay and I was going
through the casino and I saw you there
online and I was so nervous I wanted to
go up and get a picture and I was like
should I do I don't want to bother him
this is kind of weird but I gathered up
the courage and went up you were so nice
uh we took a picture together I posted
on Instagram and I was like whoa you met
Jake Cutler and so then I thought well
how cool would it be to get you on the
podcast and I sent you a DM and I'm sure
they get flooded and it must have been
six months later I think you responded
back when I was 17 or 18 I started going
to the gym consistently and you were one
of the people because I was 18 2008 and
so this was like right when you were
winning like back to back back
championships and so when it came to
bodybuilding and you know certainly like
I'm nowhere close to where you are but I
think a lot of people look to that be
like wow even if I could achieve ten
percent of that like that's the goal so
tell us about your story uh how you came
up how you got into bodybuilding in the
first place ah man it's you know it's
it's pretty lengthy I mean I can
honestly tell you guys that like from
the very beginning I mean I had pictures
when I was flexing when I was four years
old six years old eight years old I was
the youngest of seven kids and I was
always inspired by like uh cartoon
characters or Heroes right so it was
like Superman Batman and you know
Captain America those kind of things I
was always intrigued by the muscle I
would probably say the the first
influence I was 12 and my sister's
boyfriend had a bodybuilding book and it
featured the 83 82 Olympia Chris
Dickerson won that and I remember seeing
this physique and I was like man this is
unbelievable it was kind of like a
ripped up magazine and I you know since
I had already had recognition from
people around me especially my my older
brothers and sisters you know I was the
youngest of seven so uh I had a good
physique and I was an active kid I
started I guess kind of following it and
I'd go to my local GNC and I'd flip
through the books like the magazines
because that was the only real place
that had Fitness books was GNC there was
no such thing as vitamin shops or others
like Mom and Pop supplement stores so I
would go in and I would reach the
magazine rack and I watched that all
through high school I was a football
player
had an interest in bodybuilding one of
my friends when I was 15 took me to
Gold's Gym and we worked out and he was
super into bodybuilding and I think that
I kind of was like wow it's amazing what
you can do getting under these weights
and
and I I made a commitment that when I
graduated high school I graduated 91 I
was going to join the gym and start my
journey towards lifting weights and
developing a better body but what I
realized is when I started I was
attending college that fall September I
was pursuing a degree in criminal
justice I had a family business that I
worked in doing concrete so I already
had in high school a developed body but
really once I found those weights and I
found that time in the gym I was
training from eight to ten at night the
gym closed at 10 o'clock I was just lost
in the weights it was the best stress
reliever I was at that Turning Point 18
like we reached that that point it's
like the family's trying to drag it to
the business like that was a family
business and then it was like okay do I
want to pursue a degree in criminal
justice I wasn't really sure what I
wanted to do and I think a lot of young
kids just go to college and they're not
sure
is this going to be my lifelong career
and when I found lifting weights not to
say that I was like this is what I'm
going to do the rest of my life but I
knew it was a hobby for sure that I
would you know participate in and that
started the whole kind of Journey and
progression obviously kept me in the gym
I'm 50 pounds my first year training and
somehow got on our bodybuilding stage
and what about your siblings were they
Naturally Fit too like if they went to
the gym they train like you they have
the results that you did or do you think
maybe that you were just genetically a
little bit more inclined to put on
muscle I was a little stockier I have an
older brother that's a little stocky
like that also but my other brothers are
pretty slender
uh and like I said they own a concrete
business so they were all Super Active
but no one ever lifted weights so it's
hard to say would this benefit them like
it benefited me
it's really hard for me to imagine uh
you know trying to I didn't have a guide
like you know normally like the older
brother or the father like today I see
now you know someone gets someone into
this and shows them a direction where
I kind of had to find on my own I think
maybe there could have been genetics
it's hard to really say but genes do
play a part in when you can go to a
certain level like I did like the
Olympia level to win like you have to
have something special like it's
structure it's you know body composition
how you handle foods and it's a lot of
mindset what percent do you think you'd
allocate towards hard work versus just
pure genetics I think you know we've
seen some great bodies that never really
came to fruition of like being their
absolute best uh because the mindset
wasn't there but I would say you know
listen hard work like a lot of it is
hard work a lot of it but genetics you
still have to have
right genetics like anyone can make
progress
but to go to the elite level when you
start talking okay to be Mr Olympia like
you have to have a good sway of genetics
also what do you think Drew you to the
gyms in the uh the beginning in terms of
like lifting weights was it uh was it
the physique was it like hey get
attention from girls was it uh the
feeling you know I mentioned that I I
said wow if I actually
put my body to work like I would get
more reaction from people but I think
more
uh it wasn't like I get sand kicked in
my face or anything like that like you
hear these or I was smaller than
everyone else or I was picked on
I was rather popular in high school and
for me I strive on challenges in life
like if something's not competitive or
challenging I'm not I'm kind of bored
with it to be honest so at what age do
you think you crossed that line of being
like okay he's got like a decent
physique to like holy cow like this is
actually something you can compete with
Looking Back Now it was the combination
of doing concrete from 11 to 18 where I
was just working non-stop after school
school vacations it really tore my body
down so when I actually started going to
college and I would be in class and I'd
have more time to rest and then I
started eating the food because I didn't
have any kind of nutrition program at
all when I was in high school it really
uh it just my body exploded and that's
really how I
I would say that I made such fast
progression you know because my body was
just beat down tired
not not any no nutrition value
whatsoever so back to the timeline you
were 18 when you started taking it
seriously you said you also went to
college did you graduate college I did
yeah and what did you study in college
Criminal Justice Criminal Justice right
and then did you go into work right
after college did you go full into
bodybuilding the funny thing is is uh
you know I graduated college and in 90.
three
and I went to the I went to the teen
Nationals around the time I was
graduating I actually skipped my
graduation to go compete in the
Internationals yes wow that's the best
teenager in the country and I won that
in heavyweights
and from that forward I was like hey I
have something you know I was looking at
magazines and looking at California I
wasn't making a ton of money and so when
I graduated
uh I was able to
you know just work and just support my
career a little bit I didn't take a job
right away and I was trying to decide
because I graduated my associate's
degree and do I did I want to go and
finish my bachelor's and I was kind of
working I was doing heating air
conditioning at the time and uh shortly
after I mean I got my first sponsorship
offer like fifty thousand dollar
contract at the time doesn't sound like
a lot but this is this is 90.
95 Atlanta my first muscle and fitness
cover and I started getting fan mail
from all over the world I had a PO box
and I'd hand write letters to people and
you know I started a mail order and it's
kind of comical I would sell one picture
of myself and one t-shirt and people
would send me money orders and checks
and I started kind of my business at
that point every week I was getting
residual money from being basically a
nobody you know I was a guy that maybe
had a couple pictures in a magazine and
uh that's kind of how I started my
entrepreneurship to charge for a picture
shirt I would charge ten dollars for the
picture and the shirt was 20 bucks I
mean between the contract and that I
mean probably I would I would probably
make almost 100 Grand so I was doing so
I started doing some guest experiences
for 500 like guest posing and that's how
it all kind of started was just
basically
mail order and I mean it's pretty
laughable even when I was in Vegas you
know fast forward I mean I was selling
T-shirts out of my garage when no one
was doing t-shirts and making a million
bucks a year just on t-shirt sales you
know just out of my garage now back then
uh what was your overhead were you
saving a lot of it were you I was
renting an apartment my apartment was
500 bucks I drove kind of a crappy car I
bought my first I bought first car I
bought was a BMW 7 Series I think the
payment was 600 a month at the time was
huge to me I'd buy a whole cow at a time
if I had like two freezers in my house
at the time I was even probably four
meat four pounds of meat a day and a lot
of it was red meat but I buy 150 pounds
of chicken at a time
I'd buy 30 dozen eggs so I buy a whole
case of eggs and that would be my whole
refrigerator and that's how dedicated I
was and I'd sit outside and I cook in
all my chicken breasts and my steak and
stuff like that on the barbecue grill
and I put it on plates and I put in my
refrigerator and I'd pick as the days
went on prepare you know people do your
meal prep usually on Sundays or whatever
I would pick enough for each couple days
and that's how I kind of ate the food I
had pasta and rice and whatever around
it eight every two hours and you talk
about progression you know you said how
did I do it
I mean that's where I was spending most
of the money how much do you think
you're spending on food back then I was
probably spending maybe 50 000 a year on
food
gosh yeah 50 Grand back then too that
was 95. yeah because you know I would
eat out sometimes too but
uh and I would travel and so you said
you were buying a whole cow at a time
yes how much did a cow cost and how long
did it take for you to go through an
entire cow you know it was probably a
few hundred dollars for what I paid back
then that's it yeah I think it would be
more yeah I would have thought it was
like two grand no because remember this
is like this is I was the guy was in
Spencer Massachusetts so people know
people that know Massachusetts I mean I
grew up in Sterling so
uh you know it was it was I mean I think
30 dozen I just went to a grocery store
the other day I called my mom
I said Mom eggs are
five dollars a dozen here
she's I said I remember when they were
99 Cents and I mean I've probably been
in a Time Warp but I don't really pay
attention as much but when I was buying
30 dozen eggs I mean I remember I was
getting them for free sometimes because
I would publicize the Farm Stand I was
buying them from and when you're eating
four or five pounds of meat a day
it's a lot how do you eat every other
hour do you just have a fever right I
would have a clock and I would honestly
just I always have this there's this
quote on the internet and it's like
I eat for function not for Taste when's
the last time you had McDonald's well I
mean I still listen don't get me wrong I
still it's been a long time saying
McDonald's though In and Out Burger we
actually we had an Out Burger yesterday
because well we did it for YouTube oh
it's for YouTube or was it like I gotta
eat this in and out um
yeah I didn't feel I didn't I didn't I
didn't feel so good the rest of the day
to be honest but I have a specific order
that I do and I want to show like my
following that hey I am normal because I
know they think that they probably think
that I just don't
do anything outside the norm you know
what I mean do you have ever any
cravings for let's just say sweets I do
I mean I'm a carrot cake I mean
Cheesecake Factory I was one of my
go-to's when I was you know finished
with a contest over all the years and
carrot cake is one of my my vices but
you know I'm not afraid to have
something if I really but I don't like
where a lot of athletes they schedule
cheat days I don't necessarily have them
I feel like I still eat quite an
abundance of food even though I scale
but I could probably eat half as much as
I used to the diet you asked me
percentages like 80 of what we do is the
nutrition wow it's saying abs are made
in the kitchen yeah which we actually I
did I did a video yesterday said ABS
aren't made in the kitchen they're
actually made in the gym but but you
still have to you know to be visible
they're made in the kitchen right you're
still working out and very structured
and very intense about this whole you
know bodybuilding thing is there ever a
time in your life do you think that
you're gonna ease up and be like you
know what I'm not going to worry about
the food that I'm gonna eat I'm not I
don't feel like I have to push myself in
this gym so much or is it just something
that you thoroughly enjoy and you'll
think you'll enjoy for the rest I'm
still I'm still on a fast track of
appearances and and being in the public
eye social media has become kind of I
consider my yourself kind of laughable
kind of an influencer now I'm not
competitive right so I think
expectations you never want to see your
hero or someone that inspires you off
track and just normalized does that make
sense I believe social media like we
only see the positive things on social
media from certain people and you know
that it's come out at other you know
sometimes people aren't what they are on
social media what I try to do is be
as real as I possibly can and I actually
probably train now more than I did than
meaning I trained seven days a week
where before I train five days total I
got up this morning I did my fasted
cardio this morning I ate a solid
breakfast and uh you know I may not eat
every two hours or three hours like I
used to but I still try to at least four
meals a day but it's all mostly clean
eating and don't get me wrong I'll still
eat out but you know if you throw
something in front of me uh for dessert
or something like that I probably will
pass on that sure do you find that you
notice a difference if you eat fast food
or something that's unhealthy how much
do you feel it afterwards or the next
day and in and out I mean I went and
trained last night and I felt a little
heavy and I felt like the sodium really
got to me and I got everything without
salt by the way yesterday and I just it
something off track I definitely feel a
difference in your body but sometimes
your body needs it I mean it depends how
how strict you are I mean don't be
afraid to eat something that you crave
once in a while you need it for your
mind too right a lot of this like I
talked about is mental so if you your
mind is telling you hey I need something
that's off diet a little bit or
you know something that will help my
mind can you walk us through your diet
for today what exactly you ate for
breakfast and what you're gonna eat for
the rest of the day so breakfast was two
whole eggs uh
I had Ezekiel Bread which is like a
flourless bread I had a bowl of oatmeal
with a banana a cup of coffee that
cottage cheese
and I had some bacon that's still a I
mean that's a lot of food so yeah I'd be
full for yeah yeah so so the breakfast
is still 80 80 protein and probably 200
grams of carbohydrates and then I'll
have I'm not kidding like chicken and
rice the rest of the day
like chicken and rice chicken and rice
the same thing people people laugh about
my monotonous eating style it's just
what I know and I mean once in a while
I'll eat red meat I try to eat less now
over the weekend we ate at a restaurant
I did have some red meat uh but with my
age and everything I try to stay more
leaner uh less cholesterol and that kind
of thing but first you want to think
today's sponsor Rhone so Rhone sent us
their commuter shirt and I gotta say I
am wildly impressed it's not only the
comfiest shirt I've ever had but I would
say it's also one of the most stylish
shirts I've had feels like you're almost
wearing a blanket like a silk blanket
it's hard to describe actually but it's
extremely comfortable another really
cool thing about Rhone is that they have
wrinkle release technology so as you
wear and stretch out the shirt it just
gets rid of the wrinkles naturally yeah
it's perfect for Jack because he doesn't
know how to use an iron plus with their
gold Fusion anti-odor technology you'll
smell fresh and clean all day long
regardless of how sweaty you are and
that's perfect for Graham because he
always smells terrible and on top of all
of that they're 100 machine washable so
no more long and expensive trips to the
dry cleaners and I'm going off script
here but I gotta say seriously guys this
is the most comfortable shirt I've I
think I've ever had and I think you'd
agree with that right oh 100 I've worn
really expensive shirts before and this
you feels better than those shirts so
head to rhone.com iced coffee and get 20
off your entire order with the code iced
coffee that's r h o n e.com slash iced
coffee and use code iced coffee at
checkout and you get 20 off your whole
order thank you so much Rowan for
sponsoring this episode and back to the
podcast and I made the transition to
California when I was 25. so finally
after years of I mentioned you know Joe
signed me to a contract when I was 21.
gave me a raise like 10 000 bucks every
year and uh basically offered me a
hundred thousand dollars to California
at the time I was making like 60 grand
um so he gave me a forty thousand dollar
bomb to move to California to offset the
expenses and that was kind of a shock to
me and I had a really good setup in
Massachusetts I had built a home gym at
that point I had like 2 000 square foot
gym so I didn't train any public gyms
and I was traveling on the weekends you
know I was doing the mail order stuff
and at that point like I didn't have a
lot of competition because I'll be
honest a lot of the bodybuilders weren't
motivated to make more money they just
got a paycheck I mean think about it you
could sit on your couch and work out and
get paid a check every month you know
came every 30 days but for me I wanted
to build something different I thought
this was a short-term career I literally
thought
I'm gonna buy a bill for five years
and I'm gonna quit because I don't know
how successful I'll be at that so when I
moved to California and I won my first
pro show in 2000 I got fifteen thousand
dollars and I remember I was renting an
apartment at the time I was paying
fifteen hundred dollars for my apartment
at Lisa Viejo California you know I had
one car I was married at the time my
wife and I we shared that and she was a
nurse you know she was a nurse and she
got a job at Hogue hospital at the time
and and so we had dual incomes now I was
making probably 150 a year
uh but what I won that Night of
Champions I got my 15K I was able to go
buy my first home in California bought a
condo I paid 220 for it and uh that was
kind of the start and then I went on the
tour that fall I went to Olympia I
finished eighth and I went on a European
tour started collecting money and then
the next year I got second at the
Olympia and I was winning 60 Grand so
now it was starting to really roll yes
the appearances were starting to fly and
I made my first million dollars when I
was 29 years old I was a balancing a
relationship at the same time as keeping
up the schedule because I'd imagine your
schedule is like it's Gotta Be You It's
always a strain on the relationship
because it's a very selfish game like
you're eating sleeping training you're
very secluded from social
um Gatherings and whatnot what was that
like coming in second who won uh first
place Ronnie Cronin yeah so how close
were you with him at the time we were
pretty close I mean he was an idol of
mine I really wanted to stand next to
him but I was never even compared and so
when I was able to play second in 2001
next day him I was in Vegas so when it
started to migrate to Vegas obviously I
moved to California 99 also so I was
kind of a driving distance so I kind of
settled myself in Las Vegas and and uh a
week prior and I got acclimated a lot
easier than the other guys and landed
that for a second place and man it was
like I had made it like that's the first
realization that I could actually be the
best bodybuilder in the world it took a
lot longer than I expected I didn't win
until the sixth can you say how much you
make winning a Mr Olympia well at my
Peak I won 200 today it's today it's
around 400.
okay so you know I won 155 the first
year
I think I went up to 200 Max but 155 was
my first prize and doesn't seem like a
lot right be the best in the world at
something but the endorsements that come
along
it's just endless how do those look how
do you pick and choose which companies
you want to work with do you have
someone negotiating these on your behalf
I didn't come to you I didn't I was
always my own agent you know a lot of
the times uh for My Career like I I used
products or I sat looked at what could
be potentially something that I could
utilize in my career and you know
whether it's workout gloves belts
supplements clothing
I mean I had hair products I had skin
products I had tanning lotions I had
everything it just falls on your lap I
mean when you're the best in the world
or you're the most publicized guy and
back then I mean we're still talking
about magazines yeah I was on every page
of every magazine and you know I had the
biggest supplement sponsor uh company
out there MuscleTech and that was I had
an eight year contract with them now how
do you stay on top because it imagine
2006 there's a lot of pressure you're
going to do this again winning again and
and keeping that momentum how did you do
that your fear of losing
and that's how I pretty much could kind
of dictate how I train every day and
push forward I mean I I always wanted to
have a better physique but when once you
win you're
they kind of tell you like this is the
ideal physique we're looking at so it's
now duplicate that every year or
you know tried
you know try to predict what else
someone else is going to look like so
it's basically showing your strong
points and hiding your weaknesses
because we all had weaknesses for me it
was a conditioning thing like I always
my weakness was the consistency and
conditioning meaning that shredded look
without water retention I mean I could
always get lean enough it's just that
you know that last dial down of
dehydration where you have that
shrink wrapped skin on stage which lasts
a very short period I just didn't want
to lose I mean I don't I don't know how
yeah some people just strive on being
competitive and their fear of losing is
what keeps them driven and I'm not
afraid to say that you know every every
year it was you know I had nightmares of
like oh I'm going to lose the title I
wanted to win as many as I could and if
you follow my career I won two and I
lost one in the middle oh wait and then
I came back to win it again for two more
and no one's ever done that in history
and
so I I believe I mean if you ask me
honestly that's probably why I you know
kept pushing myself harder it's just
once you get that feel of Mr Olympia
it's you don't want to go backwards what
happened in 2008 and you walk us through
maybe where you feel like you could have
done better you could have pushed
yourself what what happened that day
yeah a few variables uh you know Coleman
and I battled and I want to know six
and he came back in 07 he tried to win
it back
and he finished fourth
so we carried bodybuilding to a crazy
level of size and conditioning
through our Reign it was basically a
two-man contest there was no if you look
back and
oh three four and five six no one talked
about anyone else winning it was only he
and I but there were you know 15 other
guys in the contest which was a little
unfortunate for some of the other guys
to be honest it was a little unfair but
at the same time like it was he and I
that battle and we were the biggest when
Ronnie stepped away he didn't come back
in 08 I was kind of confused on how I
wanted to bring my physique in because I
had gone so big and now I was looking at
these littler
um structured guys that were more ripped
so was I need I needed to try to become
more conditioned because my overwhelming
size probably wouldn't win it for me I
needed to be sharper
and when you try to bring your body back
down to a smaller weight
um because my first Olympia I wanted 273
and even in the 09 when I came back to
win the title was 254. so that's a big
swing of weight so I actually had to
lose a little bit of muscle in order to
gather conditioning and that's where I
went wrong it was miscalculation I was
flatter then I flatter meaning the
muscles weren't as full and um Dexter
Jackson took the title from me and it
was heart-wrenching for me yeah it was
one of the darkest places in my career
that I had been because remember I had
been first or second forever and I'd
never thought I could be beaten so I
guess it's kind of arrogance as far in
overconfident and
maybe just complacent uh places for me I
just never thought I would loot yeah and
then what did you do for 2009 I just how
did you get the motivation to to put
yourself out there I was embarrassed I
was embarrassed you know I was
embarrassed that I only held two times
remember guy
one prior to me one eight in a row the
guy prior to him won six in a row I mean
the guy prior to him won eight in a row
here I won two and lost
it's embarrassing for me so and I'm
looked upon as like the do all guy of
bodybuilding you know I was you know
super successful I was motivated I I was
driven I was like very robotic in my
routine and everyone knew that like Jay
was all business like it was no play
time for him and I think for me
everyone's like well how did this guy
Miss A Beat and just lose
so embarrassment uh extra motivated I
mean I was always better chasing like
when I chased Coleman for those years
and was second I was always you know
solidified second so now
you know here I am like they were
talking about me not even placing oh
wait like if you watch the build up to
the contest they they mentioned that Jay
won't be in the top two or three or his
body's just tired so when I came back in
09 I just kind of shut up all that that
talk and came back arguably one of my
best looks since 2001. yeah and then
what about in 2010 Bill Heath was coming
up I mean I won another one but I knew I
you know after 09 and coming back and
arguably like I said it was history
making the quad stomp that that famous
pose I did it was really hard for me to
justify
um how am I going to be better than this
my biggest fear even talking with you
know the guy that was training me in my
group around me
how was I gonna top 2009 and the truth
was is you weren't going to right it was
really hard to repeat that so for me
uh
you know I came back I won it it wasn't
in the fashion that I wanted to but that
was my last victory and I came back in
11 I tore my bicep three weeks off Phil
Heath one he was second to me in 2010
and he started his reign of seven times
I came back in 13 and I was a shadow of
myself you know after getting bicep
surgery in 2012.
and uh finished sixth what happened to
your bicep how did that happen I was
doing a photo shoot in uh basically what
I did a million times I had dumbbells on
my knees and I was kicking them up to do
a shoulder press and when I kicked them
up
the bicep detached on the upper and it
didn't hurt really I just thought oh it
was like an electric shock and I just
kept doing the photo shoot and I kept
training the leading up and it slowly
started to get black and blue and it was
actually detached and the crazy thing is
is I competed with a torn bicep I
competed there and I went to India the
next week I got second
but it was a mess you know the bicep was
all black and blue and you could see the
lump in there you know because it was
rolled down you know when the muscle
rolls is that not painful well it was
painful when I got on stage and started
posing but I didn't really
you know remember when you're practicing
you're not practicing it's like being
it's like sparring you know like no
one's hitting you with the force that
you're going to get hit with a real
fight right so it started to hurt but I
had to suck it up and the the crazy
thing is is this was September of 11 and
I didn't have surgery until February of
12 because I had so many committed guest
posings and appearances I couldn't be
slinged up or in a cast I end up in a
sling but I had to stay committed to
that
because I had already booked a million
things and I had competitions and I had
to compete
and represent I mean the fans would have
been disappointed at the time so
uh
you know that was kind of like
nail in my coffin rear my opinion it's
crazy because just just listening to
this conversation the way that you talk
you have one of the most
intense focuses that I've ever seen I
think on a guest on the podcast ever
it's you're so driven you have so much
momentum in one in one direction and I
are you feeling the same I love it yeah
it's just doing one thing really well
well like like I told you you asked me
you know about the mindset and I told
you like it's
you know I balance a lot of things now
but I try to do like one main focus
thing like at the best of my ability
right and it's kind of funny for the
shows I would basically say okay I would
train for four months for these contests
so Olympia preparation I'm it was all it
was all year but I would cut out
everything four months out meaning don't
bother me don't pick up the phone I
wouldn't even pick up the phone all
people I wouldn't do anything I would
not travel no social anything it was
like straight tunnel vision Focus for
training I was trained twice a day you
know I was in the gym twice a day I do
cardio at home two times so I was
basically training four times a day you
said in an interview or some sort of
video I watched on you this morning that
to to be as successful as you are in the
space there needs to be something wrong
with your brain can you elaborate on
that a little bit to go to the gym every
day
and destroy yourself and you have to go
to a really dark place especially the
last few weeks like you're lowering
calories and you're dizzy you're tired
and you're pushing yourself Beyond
remember we build up like like you eat
all this food and then all of a sudden
you have to pull all the calories back
to get on stage like it's kind of count
like it doesn't make sense right because
you've got to build your body up and
then strip it down so you basically have
three I have three percent body fat when
I'm on stage
and you do this over four months and
you're tired and you're frustrated and
everything else but
you know you you look amazing but you
feel like total crap and for me it's
just I it's had this mindset like it was
just super driven I can't explain it I
mean I think that not everyone can ever
build that over time it's something
you're kind of born with it makes sense
and when you look back on those years
would you consider yourself happy
no what would you say you were no I
wasn't truly happy I mean I was happy at
moments but it was just routine it was
just each Sleep Train and no repeat and
I thought I was you know we consider and
talk financial success or notoriety
and like you knew who I was or whatever
else but like I didn't sit around and
say well I'm Jay Cutler and people know
me or I make x amount of dollars it's
like I had one goal and like I told you
if I never made a dollar and I was on my
quest to be Mr Olympia I still would
have done it because it was like
something that you know history books
I'll be recognized forever that makes
sense do you find it difficult to find
determination and passion after retiring
because it feels like you've had one
focus and once that focuses I carried it
right over to the other things I was
doing it actually was like a sire relief
when I retired because like anything
everything gets old and at 40 I never
thought I'd go that long I told you I
thought I'd do it a few years I mean I I
always I've been stated in a magazine I
said I'll be retired by 30. and I had
all these other Ventures I was doing and
connections and I kind of wish I
branched out a little more because I
really could have rubbed shoulders with
a lot more people that might have you
know been
more successful or
someone that could really be kind of do
some mentorship towards me for the
future but I feel I did well uh but I
just that's how I had to operate I had
to operate like that and it wasn't about
being happy or
uh anything else and I think that it
really uh you know it gave me a lot of
opportunity to focus on my other things
you know once I stepped out and that
whole Focus was gone now I can Zone in
on you know living my life and and doing
the things that I do like I I live
nothing like that now and how did you
balance running the business and
training full-time when you were at your
Peak it it thousand it hurt me a lot to
get ready for contest so it was like
literally the day the contest was over
it's like oh thank God I can get back to
business and I get back to travel and I
focus on all my other opportunities to
you know use the success of the
bodybuilding Revenue to build a bigger
Empire and
I have a great team I had great people
around me to always help uh you know I
did I was never individual you know
anyone that tells you they're successful
solely on their own is it's probably
lying to you you know what were some of
the businesses that you were doing back
then how many income streams did you
have
um I had quite a bit I mean a lot of the
endorsements turned into uh other
business for me so I mentioned you know
I the supplements and the clothes and
you know online I had DVD sales I had
um
I have so many different like outlets
and then I was doing real estate you
know I moved to Vegas to buy property
and you know I had rental properties and
I was flipping some homes but back then
I mentioned it was so much easier I mean
Vegas was still so early this is
something that someone like yourself
probably looks and says man if I could
have been there in 2002 right I was
buying 150 000 houses and selling them
for 200 in a heartbeat and back then
that was a lot right I was putting five
percent down so it was easy to float
money back then
and then I had rental properties and I
mean the rentals were under a thousand
dollars for you know a three bedroom
house with a pool and
you know you had good and bad tenants
that's one thing I can tell you like I I
wasn't really it's hard when you're Jay
Cutler and you're a landlord
did they know of course of course
because I kind of handled my stuff and
you manage yourself unfortunately like
it was easy to rent these because I'm
out and about and someone's like I want
to come to Vegas so I have this rental
property and uh you know that's that's
how how it was how much were you making
at your Peak years can you share that
probably two two and a half million
dollars okay and what about
transitioning from that to now were you
able to invest most of that or how does
that look today yeah I mean I was able
to basically put a lot of money away
uh but I still was a huge earner and
still to this day I mean it's it just
doesn't stop and you know I was kind of
laughing with Tyler yesterday we were
talking about because he's like he sees
me traveling every weekend to these
guest appearances and he says you ever
just want to stop and he knows I'll get
bored yeah but
I said man if someone calls you and
offers you a great you know Revenue to
come out there and speak in an event or
whatever else why would I ever stop not
only do I enjoy it but it's free travel
it's connections you make I mean I
walked in a gym this past weekend
and if I didn't go do this guest
appearance I mean they had all these
murals of me on the walls and everything
like that these young kids came in and
these kids were in their teens like Jay
Cutler G and I couldn't I still floored
that these young kids
follow a guy that's older than their
parents and they watch oh I watch you on
Tick Tock or I watch on Snapchat or
watch on YouTube and I did a collab last
week with
you know a 21 year old kid and it's
getting tons of viral things and I
actually took my shirt off and posed
with them and now they're talking about
a Jay Cutler comeback and the Masters
which is crazy to me I mean I'm almost
50. this Lex little guy okay yeah he's
he's uh he's like 21 years old but you
know we got in the posing room at Gold's
Venice you know the yeah historic Becca
bodybuilding I don't know if you've been
there but you know I have pictures all
over the walls there and you know he
somehow got me in the poison room and I
had never take my shirt off
you know these guys all look good you
know they're 21 the fresh muscle and you
know for me it's hard for me to look at
you know I weigh 2 235 today and I used
to be 300 pounds and I told you I eat
that ripped full 55 275
and uh you know I didn't think I looked
so good but then the pictures are
floating I was like man Jay you should
I'm doing this whole fit for 50. so next
year I turned 50 in August and I'm gonna
get in the best shape I've been in 10
years not to say I'm getting back to
what I looked like before but I'm I'm
encouraging people like age is a number
because I honestly at my age it's I used
to look at these guys in their 40s and
say that old guy over there now I I jump
out of bed in the morning and I'm
energized to get up and do things and
that's the crazy part is I always listen
to people say oh when you're 40 when
you're 45 when you're 50 you're going to
be creeping out of bed after weight
training I have zero pain I have no
joint pain no restrictions no health
issues I mean all my blood work
everything is great now how often do you
test your blood work and make sure that
everything is in line at least twice a
year sometimes every three months but at
least twice a year I get busy and I'll
be honest I mean it's like going to the
dentist right I try to go every
three months or so I do but I'm very
conscious of my health because I
realized that
you know what I did in order to look the
weight I did uh
I definitely feel like it had some wear
and tear on my body and putting
substance in my body to try to you know
build the biggest physique I mean it's
not necessarily natural
in the food we talk about four pounds of
meat a day on the on the kidneys and
everything it's it's taxing
I mean that's just
the food is the killer yeah I mean we
can talk about drugs and dehydration and
everything else but that's what kills
people is the heart disease you know the
sugars are the worst things people don't
understand that you know too much sugar
I mean it causes a lot of it can build
up in the heart you know and that's
where a lot of people are
diabetes I mean weight challenges so for
me you know the stage isn't where I'm
kind of putting the end physique now
it's through the channels that I'm
putting the content out there in in
realization that listen because you're a
dad or
because you're you know closer to 50 or
even 60 like you don't you don't have
restrictions like oh I can't look
certain way yeah screw that right I've
been hearing a lot more stories now
about testosterone replacement therapy
and it seems like this these last five
years it's kind of come out of nowhere
maybe people are talking about it more
what are your thoughts on that I do it
yeah I do uh but the confusion is is
what is necessary for someone to replace
what they're missing they say at 35 your
levels start to drop that doesn't mean
everyone I mean with it with a balanced
diet rest patterns and everything that
suitable in stress
uh you can maintain a healthy
testosterone level it doesn't mean it's
going to go to zero but unfortunately
someone like me that used steroids on
and off through my career
it's going to have a hard time for my
body to kick back especially as I get
into my age so I've chosen the path of
testosterone therapy I take around 200
milligrams of tests a week okay it's an
injection uh that's what's been
prescribed to me and my levels aren't
crazy I mean last last test levels I had
were around 660 which is a mid-range I
mean some guys are thousands I mean if
you're you know in the twos or threes
they consider that a little lower but
not not a point where you have to choose
to take testosterone yeah I think it
helps
um obviously someone like me that
voluntarily used testosterone and other
compounds to build my career I'm going
to have a different Outlook than a
person that's probably never
used Peds ever so and I'm not a doctor
so I can't sit there and say that this
is healthy and this long term but the
the Studies have shown that you know
lower testosterone can lead to a lot of
negative side effects more than just
going and replacing it but you know
people have this misconception all it
causes cancer or this
doesn't he that's right sure I mean I
use a lot of Splenda in my instead of
sugar and they say that that's not the
best thing and
a lot of things that we drank I mean
choose a lot different routes right yeah
but I think that it can benefit I I
would just suggest to anyone if you're
feeling tired or you feel like eat or
whatever else I would definitely you
know in your blood work definitely have
your testosterone checked yeah I've
heard a lot of entrepreneurs now are
doing that Jack it's extremely popular
it seems yeah but I don't know why it
just seems like the last few years
people are I think it's Joe Rogan
because he's really talked a lot about
it I believe so yeah but he says you
have to do that in addition to training
eating rights sleeping right it's like
you know it's like it's like a
supplement right it's like I sell fat
burners or
like you have to work out and diet
around them you can't just take fat
burners and head to the shop right
there's a combination of things you need
to do but like I said you can balance
your testosterone with the with a better
diet less stress
great sleep patterns and sleep is
probably the most least spoken about
issue with people cannot sleep
because either stress or their schedules
rigid or they have sleep apnea like a
lot especially in the bodybuilding Arena
are people that have gained weight have
sleep apnea
I would say you ask percentages I would
say 30 35 of America has sleep apnea
what even is sleep apnea just waking up
choking uh you can't you can't breathe
it's blockage and you have to sleep you
know you have to go for a sleep study
test your Airway gets blocked as you're
sleeping but it happens so it's a number
not just like wake you out at Rems but
people can die people can die yeah you
can't get into deep brem because you
wake up every two minutes like choking
because you stop breathing you don't you
don't realize it right that's really
interesting one thing that I've been
hearing a lot recently as well is just
getting your blood work done in general
that you should do it like one time a
year so you can check all of your levels
because I know some people personally
that didn't realize they had a problem
and they just thought the way that they
were living was just normal life until
they got their blood work done and they
saw those statistics and numbers and
they're like holy cow this makes a lot
of sense they find supplements to fix
those numbers or whatever and then they
feel what it's like to be truly you know
balanced yeah I think at a certain age
it's important I mean not to like all
along because of what I did for living I
always had blood work done
but like class I mean people should be
checking cholesterol blood pressure I
mean a lot of people end up with
kidney issues because of high blood
pressure uh uh in that like I said it's
all like they Society stress related
um I think people drink too much
caffeine often sometimes I have to watch
out well I mean I'm I'm sick I know I
know two cups it's fine but you know I
sell pre-workouts and whatnot and I just
launched a 400 milligram pre-workout
caffeine gosh 400 milligrams yeah and I
had one I have a group I have a a club
like a thing called Cutler club and it's
a it's a whole group of avid lifters and
whatever else and I was on a live feed
last night I do these live feeds every
two weeks and I just launched this and
my guys said I probably shouldn't have
taken two scoops we took 800 Megs and
it has a lot of other ingredients what
was his work Tyler took one last night
at six o'clock a biggest mistake ever
you know how late were you up Tyler
you're up till three but he was drenched
with sweat we went and trained at kilo
club right here and uh I never seen
anyone sweat that bad oh my gosh I'd be
afraid of taking that for me one cup of
coffee is good enough
I'll be happy to send you some just to
see if you wanted dare to do that that
sounds fun you can take a half you can
take it you can take a half you know
coffee for you yeah coffee and see which
one you prefer before the workout we
kind of addressed it but why
bodybuilding does it come from a place
of insecurity no no insecurity
whatsoever it was more uh
I wanted to make my family proud I guess
my parents and uh for me uh like self
self achievement maybe I think that
anyone that goes in the gym and lifts
weights
it puts you in a different place it gets
a it's a great therapy I always say this
little drink or smoke to try to reach
what I get out of the gym if it makes
sense and you don't want to understand
until you actually get in there and your
mind is clear I could tell you at 18
when I joined that gym and I was there
from eight to ten at night all those
stresses of like the family the school
what I was going to do in life went away
I was lost in that weight training and
that's why I stayed with it and that's
why I still do it to this day has anyone
ever tried to pick a fight with you or
have you been in a fight yes what
happened can you talk about it
um I've gotten to fights I'm not someone
I mean obviously my age I'm not trying
to fight anyone today MMA is pretty
rampant like the littlest guy sometimes
can be the toughest guy but back in my
ear I mean My Size intimidated but of
course I mean you walk in a nightclub
and you know you got bigger arms than
someone else and you know the girl looks
at you and then all of a sudden and
they're like
you know and but now today I'll be
honest I mean
I'm pretty known so it's not like I'm
that person you know I'm not known as a
badass I guess if you're a UFC fighter
or something like that people want to
pick a fight with you right I mean it's
like asking Dwayne Johnson or
I mean like someone like Hulk Hogan you
know would you ask those guys like would
you think that people want to fight them
but I'm sure they've gotten their gifts
a little bit too but you know I get my
traffic stuff I mean sometimes it's like
cut you off and they start flipping you
off and
I mean I've stopped a couple times so
yeah but I'm a little bit yeah get out
of the car you just keep getting out
yeah just keep getting bigger but I
don't want to cause any altercations at
this point I feel like all you really
have to do is just like roll up this
yeah but that doesn't that doesn't mean
anything these days I mean you know if
you look at it it's scary it's really I
mean maybe to you so you know maybe
reject that see now it's going to expose
you man anyone that sees you in traffic
you're like oh that guy that guy's a
[ __ ] you know
[Laughter]
and do you think all those forces that
you had constantly being pushed onto
your body whether that be like you know
steroids or a bunch a crazy diet or
pushing yourself all the time in the gym
or all the Pre-Workout and everything
was turning you into a different
effective personality you know I don't
think you know they say these you know
these roid rages and that kind of stuff
I never necessarily had that I think
people would say when I got mad
like they just knew that I took steroids
so they like oh he's having a Roid Rage
you know what I mean it's one of those
things like if you got mad you know I'm
looking at you I'm not considering you
someone that uses Peds right so I'm kind
of like whoa that's just you know you're
at it you know you're angry like you
have maybe just the anger issue right uh
so I think it's just easy excuses you
know well that guy you know he's having
a Roid Rage or whatever but no I don't
think it necessarily changed my
personality I mean obviously as you get
your status becomes higher you get on a
certain level and you feel like a little
obligated for certain things there's no
question I mean I love to fly first
class now and I don't like to fly you
know I can't get a flight I get a little
disappointed it's not comfortable for me
so those kind of things I guess it's
just uh
more of an ego sense so I I guess you
know you would say I have to be have a
little bit of an ego if I'm trying to be
the best in the world at something I
want to be super successful but I don't
use it to look down on anyone or kind of
uh treat people differently I've also
heard that body dysmorphia is extremely
common it's very building very it's hard
to be satisfied with your physique and
you mentioned earlier you don't really
pose anymore like you said you took off
your shirt as though it was a bigger
deal yeah yeah and I can tell you that
like even when I was Mr Olympia I would
win the show and I would sit at dinner
with my crew after and I'd say how can I
be better so I don't think I ever had
body dysmorphia I realized I was massive
right I was huge I had big big arms I
mean but remember we have judges that
are telling us that we're not
where either great or we're not so great
so I would look at that more than well I
feel like I'm lagging or I'm a lot
smaller like I mean I was wearing 4X
shirts at my Peak I mean you've been
still wearing a 2X shirt and I'm not
trying to be big at all I I mean the
funny thing is I can sit in front of you
guys and you're probably saying he's not
trying to be big I mean I look still
like a bodybuilder genetically like I
said I started this thing because I felt
like if I just took that step forward
how much better could I be I was great
you know flexing at six years old and
eight years old and 12 and
you know I was one of the most muscular
kids in my high school how did they
judge by the way what do they look at
specifically so they look at symmetry
condition and proportion so basically
like the cash have to match the arms you
know the shoulders have to have a you
have to have a good taper to the waist
uh the legs have to flare
uh the condition has to be there like
the skin has to be thin the detail like
I was really detailed on my thighs in my
midsection I had really wide shoulders
so that's really what gave me a great
Advantage so when I stood there it was
just very cartoonish if that makes sense
and you have to have all those balances
and if you're missing certain body parts
it's very hard to be the best at a
competition although guys can win at
levels but when you get to stand with
the best in the world which you know Mr
Olympia is an international contest it's
usually held here every year it's here
in December this year it's been going
back and forth between Florida and here
with covet stuff but
uh
it's it's a lot of things presentation
uh you know skin tone you know your
fluent fluency and how you transition on
stage like it's just so many different
things but mainly the condition has to
be there and you have to have a really
um
uh dehydrated look how do you get that
because you were mentioning 24 hours
prior you get that like tight skin yeah
three percent body fat like what's
involved like I told you it's a four
month process to really rip down and get
like I got down to three percent and
like off season I maybe be 12 or 15. so
you you'd go on a rigid diet I mean
mostly I eat a lot of white fish I was
eating five pounds of white fish a day
so I kept my fats low and obviously
fluctuation of carbohydrates everyone
knows like a low carb diet is going to
help you clean out keto which we'd never
even knew what keto was back in my era
because it didn't exist but so basically
you restrict calories you do some
cardiovascular along with the weight
training which off season I did no
cardiovascular so no walking on
treadmills or stairs or anything like
that it just strictly weight training
you strip down and then the last week
you start cutting water out you get
dehydrated and then you know you you
start eating carbohydrates a little bit
and you find that balance of you know
cutting the water down and filling the
muscles so they push against their skin
as much as possible and you create that
shrink wrap look so it's kind of it's
kind of different where you take out the
carbs in the last week you add them back
in but you cut water at the same time so
you you get the fullness and the muscle
because a lot of carbs bring glycogen to
the muscle which is you know the filler
of the muscle so it pushes
and then you dehydrate so the skin gets
super thin and then you get that limited
time where you're just veiny and Shrink
wrapped and cut you get on stage and you
feel like hell but you look amazing
wow is it tiring when you're on stage to
like be flexing or like do you feel like
you're pushing yourself very hard yeah
you practice so every day I would do 30
minutes like at least six weeks leading
up to the contest so that was seven days
a week practice the posing so there's
like seven or eight uh poses that they
call so you see these these commercial
you'd see everyone do the frontal bicep
or you do the most muscular like those
are all part of the poses side chest
back double bicep back lat spread we
have those mandatory poses that they
call out and they put us in a line and
they compare everyone then you have your
free posing and whatever else but it's
mainly those seven or eight poses
against the other guys in a lineup that
separates you and that's how they do the
judging but it's very subjective
you know no one's punching someone out
or scoring points they're just the
judges I those physiques
and they pick out has the best flow see
I wonder how important size is because
if I look at someone like David laid
Yeah you know who he is of course he's
like I see that physique and I'm like
this in my opinion is like a perfect
fatigue he looks very much so human very
ripped shredded you know what I mean
crazy ABS crazy pecs what would happen
do you think if he tried out for a
bodybuilding competition he would do
well on a certain level
uh remember he's a Natty guy Natty means
natural you know not enhanced so at
levels like something like that with
conditioning and certain flow to his
physique now with the different
divisions in a bodybuilding contest he'd
get destroyed because he's not
on the lines of bodybuilding because
he's taller and you know when you're
taller you can have shorter guys that
are more stockier that are filled out a
little more so now you have classic
physique or men's physique which he
probably could do well in you know as
far as like trying to stand next to
someone like me that'd be really
difficult but he's a lot younger than me
and obviously he's not enhanced or
anything like that that's probably too
much for me I mean yeah it's too much
I'll never be able to achieve that but
do you think I mean he's not that big in
person guys that's a very attainable for
you it could put you on a 10-week
program and put you in that shape 10
week program get like that in 10 weeks
wow yeah really if you were dedicated
yeah and what would that what would that
involve training and probably clean up
the diet a lot I don't know how strict
you are in your diet but I feel like I'm
strict but I don't see that rate of
results how many meals a day do you eat
probably not enough uh probably two to
three I don't know if yeah your
metabolism is not going fast enough yeah
remember the more you eat it's like
feeding oh wood or fire a cold to a fire
right it or you feed it the larger the
flame gets right yeah that's kind of
Yoda thinking metabolism the same thing
so every time you shoot food at it
keeps the body burning and that's how
you want it see part of me is like I got
a bit of a belly that I got during covid
and I want to eat less to get rid of
that just to have more like a flat
stomach but I think that doesn't
coincide with you know building muscle
and so I'm in that weird in between
where it's like I I don't want to you
know grow out a gut the amazing thing is
even with your diet right now
[Music]
if I said to you Graham I want you to
walk your neighborhood every morning
when you wake up for 30 minutes well
here's what I've done is almost three
months ago I said for the next 90 days I
want to go to the gym at least five to
six days a week for one hour and so I'm
on day probably 80 something of that and
of that one hour I always do 30 minutes
of cardio and I just track on the
treadmill usually it burns between 250
300 calories I've noticed a bit of a
difference but I feel like I should be
noticing more and I don't eat dessert I
eat very little sugar the only sugar I
really eat throughout the day that I
know of is probably a little bit of
cream that I put in a coffee maybe twice
a day that won't affect you uh but in
the morning I eat a protein bar with
coffee and that's usually all I have
until probably 12 maybe 12 30. then I'll
have probably a pre-made salad at Trader
Joe's or maybe some leftovers from the
night before and then it's dinners
could be mixed up between Sushi your
protein levels are probably too low
that's probably it no I mean what's your
body weight today 130. so I would say
let's say you have a hundred pounds of
lean muscle okay if you really took the
all the stuff away
so you should take in 1.25 grams of
protein per pound of in body mass so you
should let's say you need 125 grams of
protein you're probably not taking in
that much probably
you know what I mean even if you eat
think about it even if you ate 40 a meal
four times three it's only 120 grams
right now and you probably have 40 a
chicken breast the eight ounce chicken
breast is like 40 grams of protein right
I mean 12 egg whites just an egg whites
like three grams of protein or egg white
so you'd have to eat 12 egg whites to
eat 36 grams right and you're probably
not eating that so I think you're
probably if you if you bumped your
protein up even if you used a protein
shake or whatever it'd be happy I'll be
happy to send you some cups I would love
to try it we should have brought the
we'll make sure to try that I'll be
happy to shout out your supplement
companies yeah cut the nutrition very
easy yeah there we go what advice would
you say you have for my physique if I'm
trying to get that David late look
obviously I can't get that first of all
you gotta shave the arms you know it
will show more muscle definition yeah
well look at look at his pictures he's
does not make body hair moving on my
chest here on my arm hair because it
hides well you know that you know that's
that's the weirdest thing like when I
started training
you know I remember doing the
competition like you need to shave
everything okay everything because
remember we had to put on these little
posing trunks that was the strangest
thing for me like it took a lot of work
to shave down the body like at a razor
I'd have someone do it for me
and it was continuous once you start you
can't stop like to this day like I'm
still shaving my arms and my chest and
whatever I just don't let kind of grow
out like that and you know I tried doing
waxing for a while on my back and
everything because once you shave your
back it's like it grows like crazy
and uh you know that's probably like
maintenance is the hard part but I would
definitely say
uh you know just focus on getting leaner
I mean you're looking at David and
saying that's inspiring to you
remember it's all about being cut and I
I could tell you that both you guys need
to clean your diet up a lot like Focus
if you said
okay for five weeks or whatever I'm
gonna stay or pay attention to a good
diet you'd see a lot of progress so for
the past couple of weeks ever since
honestly we had liver King on the
podcast which was like a million a month
ago maybe yeah I've been really just
eating like a Chipotle Bowl
which is usually what I have for lunch
and then chicken and potatoes or chicken
and rice or steak in your training
consistently yeah I would say
consistently yeah what did the liver
King teach you guys the like if you
walked away with one thing you got out
of him for on physique wise was what the
liver the liver you deliver yeah he says
like basically like high protein I've
never I've never had liver you haven't
um you does any part of you want to
absolutely not yeah same with me he's
got crazy ABS that guy yeah have you
seen his AB routine I watched a little
bit yeah that's crazy one of our
influencer friends actually shot a video
with him this guy Jesse James West yep
he's one of my favorite YouTubers yes
he's a lot of energy yeah we've done a
couple videos together and he uh and he
kind of told me like the liver Kings
team kind of like did all set up
everything that was inside that video
because normally he's like very
structured with how he shoots Jesse you
know he's very methodical about his
approach on doing his YouTube videos
he's very dedicated he actually you you
know what's funny is that he called he
was living with David
and they came to Vegas and he hit me up
Jesse wasn't super popular then and he
said I want to shoot a YouTube and Dave
you know David came and he didn't work
out with us but Jesse shot with us now
he was at 500k and he's like I'm gonna
hit a million by the end of the year
that's my goal and I was kind of like
okay yeah whatever you know and he went
up to a million now he's at two yeah but
you know it's non-stop like we were just
in La last last week together shooting
for young LA and
and he was like telling me I'm doing
this project this project and he's he
just texted me yesterday and he's like
hey can I get you and Ronnie Coleman
together you know because he shot with
Ronnie Coleman recently and you know
he's always thinking like what's the
next thing yeah but the liver King I
mean I'm intrigued by what he kind of
puts out there and uh I still don't
understand a lot of it I mean crazy
midsection on the guy but are you doing
abs Morrison seeing his abs did he sit
here with his shirt off yeah yeah he
doesn't put on a shirt really yeah and I
was saying like whatever even at the
casino I'm like you're staying at a
hotel do they go away on the shirt he
goes no I'm liver King I don't wear it
they don't care huh I saw him on the
Strip greeting fans in a video wow yeah
yeah that's what he was here for so he
did something so so what'd you learn
liver liver I mean he he just said take
what was it immense momentum in One
Direction which is kind of what I
alluded to you a little bit earlier I
honestly learned a lot but not much of
it was like about like physique or
physical activity it was more other
stuff yeah I think the the most
surprising part was his diet uh was a
lot of raw meats and that for me like I
could like he brought out a whole plate
of like there was a testicle on there
liver heart kidney did you eat it yeah
what did it taste like honestly okay no
don't say horrible yeah you're gonna say
horrible I was about to say honestly
the testicles definitely was one of my
least favorites just flavor I even know
you know
aside what it is what kind of testicle
old testamental it had apparently been a
last morning I mean it was like yeah
like that yeah that was pretty gross uh
the kidney was really gross because
that's what filters you know you're in
yeah so it kind of honestly tasted like
urine the heart was they say urine's
good for you to drink though really yeah
who says that like remember that boxer
was drinking his own urine you don't
remember that when he fought Mayweather
yeah no he didn't win anything he didn't
win of course either no one wins yeah
but yeah the the liver was decent and
the heart was good the heart was
honestly kind of steaky and those cuts
tasted a little like Sashimi see I don't
know like
ah man I don't know if I could do that
you should do something with liver King
I know but I don't think I can eat that
stuff but neither did I I he brought it
in and it was professionally prepared
like the chef you could tell this was
like
like Michelin star sort of preparation
and it was cooked or no it was raw
but they get it but they seem to get it
so fresh it's cut in these like little
tiny squares
um I think I would have had an easier
time had I not known what that was like
if they told me oh this is seafood it's
like sushi probably would have had an
easier time it's the mental aspect see
that's the thing with me is like you
asked about like eating out and what
like isn't I just can't venture to
try any like I've never had Kentucky
Fried Chicken never had Taco Bell Taco
Bell I had I actually had Chick-fil-A
for the first time what'd you think
weeks ago yeah I kind of gave me a
stomach ache you could be honest grilled
chicken or the fried I think I got like
a spicy chicken sandwich and I had the
waffle fries would you like this waffle
fries they were pretty good they were
good but like I don't know if I'll go
back to be honest sure like I I still
feel like you're inhibiting yourself
from enjoying life I I am I am and I
think it stems from how I grew up I mean
I grew up
you know a household like I said seven
kids you know my dad my parents
separated when I was four so my dad
pretty much kind of raised my mom moved
to Florida and uh we weren't allowed to
have sugar cereals they had no
McDonald's so you asked me about
McDonald's like we didn't have one
locally like we had to travel ways to do
it and we go to the grocery store my dad
would cook all these huge dinners every
night and uh we were very restrictive to
what we had so I guess it stems from
that and I was really kind of uh
introvert if that makes sense where I
didn't I never slept at anyone's house
ever uh I never like I stayed out and
did things with other kids but I wasn't
I had like mainly two friends all
through high school that were like super
close to me I mean I was friendly with
everyone but I was just really secluded
from a lot of things I think that's you
know how I was brought up you should do
a video with liver King you should you
should have them on your podcast yes you
guys did a video together or you went to
his place and you did What's called the
Barbarian yep I tried this morning for
that yeah this would be a video
guaranteed I don't know what that is
though that's what Jesse James Quest did
oh he did okay drag the sled okay 130
pounds 20 pound ankle weights on each
hand you're wearing a backpack that has
I think 70 pounds in it and you're
holding 70 pound kettlebells in each
hand you walk a mile and you can never
take the backpack off with that though I
would have no fear of failing I mean you
would be able to do it easily you know
you say that but
just because I'm me and like what I've
achieved 20 years ago Dude is different
from now no I mean I'm not the same
person remember I'm almost 50.
so it's a lot harder to do things the
gym like I pick up weight I look at some
of the weights I used to do like I used
to take a 200 pound dumbbell and hook it
with my fingers like this and row it no
problem and I literally went to move
150s at the gym the other day and I
thought I was going to tear my bicep
still man your 50s like most people's
prime prime at like you know 20 I know
but I'm Jay Cutler it's different right
I mean that's the thing is yeah when you
say like how did you prepare yourself I
used to look in the mirror and be like
okay you're not normal you know you're
Jay Cutler it's like people used to say
how'd you get psyched up and go to the
gym and sometimes it's loud music
sometimes it's like switching gyms
having training Partners I used to fly
people in and out to kind of challenge
myself but a lot of it was looking in
the mirror and being like okay this is
your job this is what people expected
I have one of those things like every
week and I travel it's like you hear one
more story of how someone was inspired
by this crazy thing that I did that I
have no idea I even forgot that I did
and that's really what kind of continues
uh to be a driver for me yeah did you
ever have any financial goals like hit a
million net worth before 30 10 million
before this age I never really did I
mean I always said that I want to retire
from bodybuilding and
you know not have to struggle
and I think you know there were certain
things I wanted to buy a home you know I
want to drive a nice car my original
goal was to buy a Corvette driving
across the desert with the top down like
that was my dream of when you listen to
Journey soundtrack I had all these like
little things and I blew past all that
but never uh you know although I've
reached a you know Financial Freedom I
still to this day don't talk about
if I could make this or make that it's
more you know when you have a brand and
you are the brand it's more about being
recognized I think for me if you said in
in the end like what is your whole goal
with this thing and
I want to be
spoken about as like one of the greatest
bodybuilders ever and that means all
around not just competitive but
like giving back and people learning
from and you know being a figurehead
that is inspiring to people in all
aspects and I feel I've kind of achieved
that in a sense I mean just by the
feedback that I get in my interaction on
social media like
I try to learn and you know I surround
myself with a younger generation of
people
and you know that's that's kind of
really you know what intrigues me now
because everything is moving so fast and
what a year ago is was happening is way
different from today so what's your
strategy right now with social media do
you have platforms that you prioritize
um yeah I mean I'm still working YouTube
consistently
um Instagram obviously has been
something that was introduced to me back
in 2012 and I have all my business on
there I use Facebook still I have six
and a half million on Facebook so I
still utilize I still think that has an
audience Tick Tock I think has really
been the most thing people have talked
about over the last year
and I brought someone on to you know to
help me with that to kind of understand
it a little better so I'm just creating
more informational hosts now meaning
instructional and and more about mindset
uh motivation for people and really to
show like Knowledge from someone that's
been there done that so I think the
content is really you know not like I
mentioned the podcast is important for
me because
it's not just me going to the gym and
Visually you watching it's like getting
into the mindset okay how do you prepare
for this you know I talk about my travel
experiences I talk about some Finance on
there
I think right now everyone's in fear of
what's going to happen over the next
three to six to 12 to 24 months I mean
we don't know what direction it's going
we keep hearing all these every time I
turn on YouTube and I watch a lot of
Finance people
all I hear about is like get ready for
the worst destruction ever you could
thank this guys look at that you know
they don't know what's coming and it's
like month after month here we are
and the world hasn't fallen apart yet
you know and and we talk about you know
I watch Vegas real estate because
so many people are moving here for the
state income tax and leaving California
and they're going to Texas or other
places to Florida
but
everyone wants to buy a home like oh is
the crash gonna come like 2008 and I
don't think we're going to see 2008
again I was in 2008 which by the way was
my biggest earning year in professional
bodybuilding ever because everyone went
to the gym and started buying
supplements that year when they lost
their jobs and they were depressed but
will we see a reduction you know 20 or
would I mean think that's what they're
kind of saying I think yeah it depends
on the year I mean the rates are scaring
everyone but I know people are still
buying because they're like you know
what I'll just refinance right they
think the rates are going to come back
down to two but we've never seen it's
like it's like gasoline going back down
to three right is it going to happen
that's what everyone is saying right now
is that they're oh no a few years
they'll pivot and then I'll refinance it
you know four or three I don't know if
that'll happen we could stay at five six
for when I when I took the loan on my
home
2007 the current home I live in and I
paid five and a half percent back then
that was an amazing rate so when we got
down to our two and a half you know
realistically three let's say what it
was I mean I know people talked about a
two percent depends
exactly so yeah in my my credits A Plus
and everything so man I don't know if
we're gonna see those days right I think
so
I mean that's kind of free money in a
sense uh even my one of the auto loans I
had on one of my vehicles you know I
bought a G wagon with the benefit tax
benefit you know I got a 1.9 interest
rate was that before 2021 I bought it
okay so that was right as they were
selling over MSRP I got it I got it
slightly over sticker okay uh
and now it's still going way over
sticker but I financed through Mercedes
for six months just to ask you to hold
that and then I refinanced with Bank of
America and I got a 1.9 today I you know
I I called months ago said what's the
rate at five percent yep
so it's inflation I mean if you're on
there shouting about
you know what the Market's going to do I
think that's everyone's living in fear
right now and I mean listen airline
tickets I fly consistently it's like
double what it was last year pandemic I
remember one of my friends who had
over a hundred doors you know it called
me I'm so scared because you know
pandemic thing and I remember thinking
oh it's going to go away
and all of a sudden it's like they
locked us down and it was like oh wow yo
yep I never imagined in my life
that the world would close
yeah I remember that for for months and
that's what uh for me really pushed me
full time to YouTube until then I was
like you know 80 YouTube I was still
doing 20 real estate on the side but
when everything shut down I went a
hundred and like 10 it was all I did so
you benefited from it but you just said
that your physique suffered oh yeah well
part of that was because I was doing so
much on YouTube that I thought I'm gonna
put my physique aside put like the
health aspect aside because I'm gonna
get more Roi right now doing YouTube and
like making that my focus so if I get an
extra hour on YouTube that to me was
better than an hour this is what I've
tried to preach not to do your health is
everything right your health is
everything that you
like without perfect health how
successful are you
right I mean well I mean my my thought
was that I could always get back to it
of course I mean that's always I was
just like you know sitting home eating
like all the time but it was just
instead of going to the gym for an hour
get an extra hour work and now the same
same people I think they can buy a house
at seven percent interest rate and say
well I'll get back to the lower interest
rate right but I have gone back to the
gym made it consistent uh not to the
same degree as I was Prior but I'd say
pretty good and how do you feel after
you train every day great you feel like
a like Clarity and uh I would say 85
maybe 90 of the time I do yeah yeah I
don't notice a huge difference going
into the next day I always feel better
afterwards
I don't know if I if that like carries
forward through the next day I I think
it does I haven't really noticed a huge
difference and so your positive message
to anyone that watches your content
you would just say consistency is
necessary because you just said you'd
sacrifice to have be more consistent
with you media right yeah it has to yeah
did you say your YouTube is your biggest
uh asset to yours success 100 yeah
and but during covet there was so much
happening every day that I couldn't
afford to miss one upload one thing and
so that was sometimes I I even post like
some it's like back to back every day
because there were things that if I
didn't talk about this someone else was
yeah and I'm not gonna get another
opportunity so Arnold Schwarzenegger
said that nowadays bodybuilding is
basically a bunch of like roided out
people and it isn't very aesthetic
anymore basically people see these
bodies and are turned off from the sport
rather than turned on to it and I know
back when you were competing in your
Heyday that was a lot different than
what it is today today uh what's your
opinion on this do you think that it
people have lost sight of the whole just
like idea of something being aesthetic
and they fill that in with just being
massive and I don't I don't think that's
true necessarily yet or there are some
what we call freaks which is actually a
good thing in bodybuilding
uh
you know it's really it's tough for
someone like Arnold who was in That 70s
era to look at the physiques and think
they're not going to advance you know
it's kind of like professional football
where you know Lyman Billy broke 300
pounds and now if you're not 350 or you
know what I mean you just you can't even
be competitive I think that
you know we still have some Aesthetics
but yes there are some Mass monsters I
am a victim of becoming bigger than what
I probably should have but I needed to
absolutely win and I mentioned that
Ronnie and myself were bigger than
everyone else and that's what kind of
the judges
put us in first and second place
the advancement of everything is
sometimes uh not looked upon by our
former Champions uh to be as as
productive or
attainable there's no question uh the
food has become more extreme the
supplements have advanced the weight
equipment itself has become something
that's different like we have way more
machines like look at the leg difference
from Schwarzenegger's era to now I mean
guys their legs are crazy I mean I had
some of the best legs in bodybuilding uh
where it was very uh few people that had
that kind of leg development back in the
era but they did bring back classic
bodybuilding to be a little more
streamlined than the Open men's
bodybuilding but I would somewhat agree
with Arnold but disagree in a sense like
in the end I mean it's advancement of
everything and and there's a lot of
variables that go into it it's not just
the steroid use I would wouldn't look
upon that uh there are other compounds
that are being used that maybe weren't
available in Arnold's era but like he
wasn't drug free himself so I mean it's
it's uh
you know not everyone you know it's kind
of an open field we don't necessarily
have drug testing in it so it's easy for
his perception to be like this is what
causes it but I believe that uh
definitely things have advanced
sometimes for the better or worse uh but
you'd still have some Aesthetics mixed
in with mass monsters too and uh you
know in the end it's it's really down to
the judging into deciding who is going
to be the first place winner at these
major contests if you were to pick out a
defining like muscle or feature on your
body that you think as like the iconic
Jay Cutler muscle and then one that you
think that you could have worked on more
it's the quads for sure for me I mean I
had tons of detail I had striations I
mean the quad stomp is something I'm
known for especially with the younger
generation now uh for me you know my
back held me back or against Ronnie
Coleman because he was just so advanced
in the back area like I mentioned the
conditioning Factor was always the
downfall to me meaning my consistency
from show to show to have perfect
conditioning we talked about that
dehydration process and you know making
sure the muscles full enough and wrapped
that was probably the downside I was
definitely not blessed with a small
waist so I had to offset with larger
legs and larger shoulders to create like
I mentioned that V taper so you want to
have the V taper you know and the legs
come out so
it's definitely uh you know like I said
everyone's gonna have their strong and
their weak points if that makes sense
and when you're working out what's your
favorite workout day like back or legs
because they're the most challenging
really I hate by arm training it's so
boring to me because it's so repetitive
it's either you know curls or press
Downs or whatever else for triceps
uh but I love the challenging Loops like
the leg training remember the legs are
half the body and the back training like
I mentioned I would had a week back
against some of the greats early on so I
had to really improve that you know Mr
Olympia is not one
by anyone without us tremendous back
what do you listen to at the gym I don't
listen to anything
yeah I mean I half the time I don't have
a headset
you know the gem I train at doesn't have
a lot of loud music
um sometimes I don't even hear the music
I'm so zoned in I really have a playlist
I do get approached but I train it or
gyms now that I don't have that
issue
um but I do uh
like when I went to Venice last week
obviously took a million pictures when I
was there I didn't have a headset or
anything so a lot of times I just I'm
paying attention of what weights I'm
pushing and my mind to muscle
connections if it makes sense uh
training for me now is meditation
meaning like it's a time where I can
kind of Escape any kind of thought
process and my goal to go in the gym is
just to not
not think about any problems or
priorities it's about putting my mind
into that muscle and just working and
just putting my headspace in an absent
area where I don't have any stresses or
have anything that's on my mind
whatsoever it's an Escape like I get up
and do my facet cardio this morning and
it's meditating for me
So when you say what do you listen to
listen to all the things in my head that
you know I try to escape from and just
try to have a clear mind one thing I
hear a lot and one thing liver can
really emphasized when he was on our
podcast is the fact that you need to get
your body right before you can get your
mind right because he there are a lot of
parallels that are drawn between people
that are like physically fit and also
successful entrepreneurs or successful
in whatever field that they're in do you
find this to be true being around people
that are it carries over I think if you
take care of your physique
and you know you're happy I mean how
many people wake up in the morning and
look in the mirror and say
I'm happy with the way I look and that's
the
knowing like my fan base
I mean 98 of the people wake up and say
I'm not happy with how I look I mean I
can tell you I'm one of those people
like I always want to see
self-improvement so I think that it
carries over
into everything that you do so yes
getting the body right I mean we
mentioned the health aspect I mean want
to be healthy
some people view Health they don't look
inside they look on the outside first
and then you know they they concern
themselves I mean it should be the
opposite way but uh you need a lot of
like I said it's not just like going to
the gym and working out you're not going
to see automatic results it's the
nutrition and the Sleep patterns and
everything so your body needs to be
right in order for your mind if you know
if you don't get sleep
you know or if you don't have a way to
relieve stress how functional is your
mind going to be
if you're a distressed audio I mean
that's why weight training can be so
therapeutic for people
sure it works well for you I mean you
know I still have goals like I can't
wait to go to the gym today
sitting here at this interview I'm gonna
do back today but I can't wait to train
like if you said well you know you asked
about like hey what are your goals and
whatever but my goal is to go to the gym
every day and have the best workout ever
I mean I'm gonna go to the office after
this and I'm gonna focus on business and
do some phone calls answer some emails I
didn't get to this morning can you tell
us your back routine yeah I'm going to
start with uh today I'm going to start
with pull-ups I'm going to do wide grip
pull-ups and then I'm gonna do reverse
grip pull downs I'm gonna do bent
barbell rows reverse grip I'm going to
do a one-arm dumbbell row and I'm going
to just seated cable rows with a closed
grip I already know because I already
thought about this before wow that was
like like every day every day every day
because it's always different but I
already went through I visualize
the day prior like what I'm going to do
so when I walk in the gym it's like
it's just not even it's robotic right
but I already visualized like how many
I'm gonna do eight to twelve repetitions
or whatever I'm gonna do 12 I'm gonna
try to get 12 reps
but I'm gonna I already know like
looking I can already visualize the
weight stack and putting 180 on the
seated cable rows and I'm gonna I'm
gonna do one arm rows with a hundreds
um like you already know I'm gonna shoot
for at least eight reps with the
pull-ups you know body weight pull and
is there a specific workout or one rep
or something that you look back on you
remember that to be one of the hardest
or if not the hardest thing yet you've
had to do for example like maybe you
were doing bench and there was like you
said when you did what was it like 500
or something for 550 yeah 550 for two
like that second rep right there or
maybe you got like a nosebleed or
something when you were working no you
know I used to squat until my nose bled
if that makes sense so we had this
mirror at the Gold's Gym in Worcester
Massachusetts and there was a lot of
spit on the mirror because the squat
wreck was up against the mirror so the
guys would you ever see the guy Squat
and they they go and they and
but I would actually squat until
like so much blood it was like my nose
would bleed you know and I thought that
was the coolest thing at 18 and you guys
are sitting here like what the hell yeah
but you know listen that's that's what I
mean like you have to be a little
mentally messed up to push yourself
think about that I'm sitting on you know
people look at me as like oh you know
Jay is a successful you know
entrepreneur bodybuilder you know one of
the smarter guys in bodybuilding and I'm
sitting here telling a story how I
squatted to my notes how great that was
like that's the levels we pushed
ourselves to that was the metric was
like okay we're good but you know I used
to do lunges I remember Gold's Gym
Sahara Decatur we had a Gold's Gym there
it's out of business now and I literally
would drag the bar outside and I put 225
on the bar and I would do walking lunges
in 120 degrees and I thought that was
the coolest thing ever and I remember
like throwing the bar off my back and
trying to catch my breath in the air so
heavy because it's over 100 degrees and
you know the Summers I was training for
Olympia so this was like July think
about that the bar would just be burned
oh well it was hot you know but I would
stay out there for maybe you know 15
minutes doing these lunges back and
forth you know I would do at least 10
steps per leg and uh I thought that was
the coolest thing ever because I was
striving to be the best in the world at
what I did and I used to think this is
what's I'm going to think about when I
stand on Olympia stage and win the title
and it's exactly what I thought about
like I I kind of had flashbacks every
time I won
like of what it took to get there I
remember like being in Massachusetts
trudging through the snow to get to the
gym and Worcester when I first started I
remember driving to Maine and
you know two hours up there so my
nutritionist could I take my clothes off
so he could see how I looked and any
congestion to my diet and drive two
hours home I'd spent four hours in the
car and literally 15 minutes like in his
condo so he could just my diet and then
drive back I did that on my all my days
off I'd fly all over the country
to do tissue work I did massage therapy
like neuromuscular therapy and eye
therapists all over but I had one in
California so when I moved out of Aliso
Viejo and I moved to Vegas I would fly
back on my days off every week to have
this guy work me for an hour and I would
fly back I mean it cost me 500 for the
you know trip back and forth but I
didn't care because it was you know
tuning my body to be better on stage so
we talked about the prize money at the
Olympia I spend all that 150 or 200 on
all preparations you know you hear about
LeBron James he spends a million a year
to his body to be his best
like that was my I mean that was my
asset so I I figured okay if I could
keep putting the money into it and today
I attribute a lot of that like
dedication to my success of walking
around without pain
still being able to train a lot of guys
in my arrest can't train like this
they're finished like they just have
aches and pains and are they just not
interested like
like I said bodybuilding it was
something I loved when I was 12 and
I still love it just as much today and I
don't plan on competing again but you
know I have different goals what's this
so this is the newest Adventure so this
is a pet butter so I have one that's uh
it has glucosamine and and whatever in
it but this is more of a flavored one so
this is for dogs you know it's a little
treat for them so it's it's basically
healthy peanut butter because a lot of
peanut butters don't have great
ingredients but this is the start so
these are my two little little ones here
so that's daising oh by the way oh my
gosh so this is my newest uh
um kind of launch out
the start of my pet products yeah we
can't say the word
enut utter oh because she goes nuts oh
yeah that's the one food where she just
goes crazy for us so I wanna wait I want
yeah so when you check it out you know
you just mix it up a little bit and uh
give her a little bit okay or whatever
and uh wow can humans eat this of course
yeah it tastes really good actually
really yes of course I take it I give
one for the dogs and one for me no way
because actually right now this morning
I literally ran out yeah so if you
kidnap one of these it's okay okay this
one actually this one has uh more flavor
to it than that because that's more uh
for joints and everything else that wow
added glucosamine
so yeah I'm looking at the ingredients
like this sounds delicious
so put this put this on your uh on your
toast tomorrow morning
how do you stay looking so young it's
almost 50 I mean yeah yeah actually yeah
is it water as well yeah I drink a lot
of water uh
you know I use sunscreen I use a lot of
lotions I try to stay out of the Sun as
much as when it's crazy I live in Vegas
right you stay out of the sun you know
you I have a pool in my backyard too but
I I think you know I walked outside this
morning actually I did my cardio around
my neighborhood and uh
I think stress
you know we talk about stress and I
think that
I'm a very relaxed person and nothing
really gets to me like I'm super chill
and laid back and I feel that stress and
I don't drink or smoke
I don't know if that has something
I don't know yeah if you ask me that
question I don't I don't know I feel
like
you know I see myself aging but at the
same time I guess uh I guess you're
comparing me versus some other people
maybe at that age yes and I think that
the better question is to ask those
people why look
right that's good cool is there anything
else Jack no let me let me double check
make sure I hit every one of these yeah
hey that's it is there anything else you
want to talk about no I mean you know I
appreciate you guys having me on and
like I said I've I'm always interested
it's so cool that you're local here like
you know and I I wish when you met me
originally you would have said hey I I'm
actually on YouTube or you know maybe at
the time you weren't interested
a video about I was I messaged you right
afterwards oh really okay so you know
it's just like I said uh you know my
message to everyone is
you know the consistency in life
and I think that if you asked me like
what
what kind of drives me is you know
having the feedback remember I travel so
much and I get feedback from people on
you know why why they follow me and
sometimes I ask people how do you know
who I am because they're a younger
demographic or they'd look like they'd
necessarily don't work out right
and it's just the smallest thing like I
picked up a magazine or I saw something
on social media and it's it's relating
to like something that I did in my life
and I think that's the coolest thing
ever because selfishly I work to become
the best bodybuilder in the world and
honestly all I cared about was
you know in the beginning getting
featured in books uh
you know winning on stage having all
these I have a crazy Trophy Room at my
house and I look around that room and I
don't get the satisfaction I did 20
years ago because I'm not in it anymore
and I think that you know there's going
to be more Champions that come along in
bodybuilding but there's going to be
more people in life that you know follow
people on different aspects and I think
it's a unique opportunity for me to have
the platforms that I do it's very
interesting to see someone like yourself
that
probably sure that you'd never imagined
it would be this level right so we keep
spreading our messages and I'm all about
positivity and you know just consistency
with what you do one thing I can say
about content
and messages it has to be constant and I
think that someone listening to this
will learn that you know much driven and
focused I was like it was a lot of
consistency
right in life and in general so
relationships
you know lifestyle everything's constant
so you guys have me you're welcome we'll
link to everything down below in the
description
really appreciate it and I can't wait to
hear about this Barbarian challenge I
can't wait to uh
maybe see the physique progression all
right you know don't don't let him kind
of beat you as far as train train this
morning I was dragging the sled I was
wearing the backpack we were yeah
kettlebells and hands 57 pounds so don't
let me down so I expect you to complete
the challenge when it we said January
right January and you're gonna film it
right yep I can't wait to see it yeah
cool thanks man I want the connection to
liver King just let us know I appreciate
that so much everybody knows who I am so